Things like fold fusion. And it's called deforestation because of the process of removing trees. And he using these algebraic laws transforms that program into a linear Cadane's algorithm solution. And in the midst of that paper, he mentioned something called the fold scan fusion law. Right. So the anamorphism is a, the opposite of a fold. Where you're going from a seed value, it's an unfold. Yeah, an unfold.
比如折叠融合。之所以叫删除树（deforestation），是因为这个移除树的过程。他利用这些代数定律，将该程序转化为卡达恩算法（Cadane's algorithm）的线性解法。在那篇论文的中段，他提到了一个叫做折叠-扫描融合律（fold scan fusion law）的东西。没错。因此，anamorphism（anamorphism）是一种，折叠的对偶。即从一个种子值出发，它是一个展开（unfold）。是的，一个展开。
Going from a seed value to a sequence, let's say. And catamorphism is the generalization of going from a fault, going from a sequence to a summation value. And so the hyalomorphism is where you fuse them both together. You don't need to generate the sequence in the middle, as it were. Welcome to ADSP the podcast, episode 281, recorded on March 30, 20, 26. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host, Ben, we chat about Haskell deforestation, hylomorphisms, the boost ranges, jello, and more.
比方说，从一个种子值到一个序列。而 catamorphism（catamorphism）则是将折叠进行泛化，也就是从一个序列到一个求和值的过程。所以 hylomorphism（hylomorphism）就是将它们两者融合在一起。可以说，你不需要在中间生成这个序列。欢迎来到 ADSP 播客，我是第 281 期，录制于 2026 年 3 月 30 日。我是 Connor，今天我和我的联合主持人 Ben 一起探讨 Haskell 的删除树、hylomorphism、boost ranges、jello 等等。
I mean, I sent you some topics of like a rabbit hole that I kind of... Yeah, he sent me some cryptic topics, I have to say. Algebra laws, BMF, Haskell Deforestation. Are you familiar with Haskell Deforestation? Does that mean anything? I'm not familiar with any of these things, really. BMF, I looked up, is that... Well, I'm assuming it's... Is that Bird Merton's formalization? Yes. I think formalism, if I'm...
我的意思是，我发给你的一些话题就像是一个我掉进去的兔子洞……是的，他发给我一些晦涩难懂的话题，我不得不说。代数定律，BMF，Haskell 删除树。你熟悉 Haskell 删除树吗？这有什么含义吗？我对这些东西其实都不太熟悉。我查了一下 BMF，那是……嗯，我猜它是……那是伯德-默顿形式化（Bird Merton's formalization）吗？是的。如果我没记错的话，我想是形式化……
Formalism? Sure. And so, I mean, there was two different. Let's let me open. And this is the process of algorithmic transformation of programs, typically inside the compiler in a functional language compiler. Similar to deforestation, so it ties in with that. So wait, so you...
形式化？当然。所以，我的意思是，有两种不同的。让我打开来看看。这是程序代数转换的过程，通常在函数式语言编译器的内部进行。类似于删除树，所以它与此相关。等等，所以你……
Which is the same idea. You weren't familiar with deforestation, but then you just referred to it. So have you heard of it before, or... I've heard of it. I know almost nothing about it, but having... having read half a Wikipedia page, I constrain together a few sentences. Yeah, let me, what is the... So I'm trying to find the paper.
这是同一个概念。你对删除树并不熟悉，但你刚才却提到了它。所以你以前听说过吗，还是……我听说过。我对它几乎一无所知，但读了半页维基百科之后，我就可以把几句话拼凑在一起了。是的，让我看看，什么是……所以我正在试图找到那篇论文。
So I gather that it's related to things like Foul Fusion. And it's called deforestation because of the process of removing trees and simplifying tree structures. Is that why it's called that? Because honestly, I haven't actually gone and read the paper yet. Well, I have to think, it's a Philip Wadworth. Philip Wadler used that expression in a paper deforestation. Yeah, it was, because that's the thing is, I have too many now of these, of these deep-dive papers that I've had, you know, these research engines go and build.
所以我理解它与像“折叠融合”（Foul Fusion）这样的东西有关。之所以叫删除树（deforestation），是因为移除树和简化树结构的过程。这就是它这么叫的原因吗？因为说实话，我其实还没去读那篇论文。嗯，我想想，这是菲利普·瓦德勒（Philip Wadworth）写的。菲利普·瓦德勒（Philip Wadler）在一篇关于删除树的论文中使用了这个词。是的，就是这样，问题在于，现在我有太多这种深入研究的论文了，都是我让这些研究引擎去生成的。
Yeah. I'm trying to. Well, this touches on, I'll let you search. Well, I'm just looking for, because I have these three different, three different papers, and all of them have to do with Richard Byrd's algebra laws. So he's the author of the algebra of programming, which I have not read yet, but I know that you've put it on my radar. So I assume that you've read or at least perused it at some point in time. I have, now, if you're going to put me on this part, I can't remember what's in it.
是的。我正在尝试。嗯，这触及了……我让你先搜。嗯，我只是在找，因为我有这三篇不同的论文，它们都与理查德·伯德（Richard Bird）的代数定律有关。所以他是《程序代数》（The algebra of programming）的作者，我还没读过，但我知道你把它列入了我的雷达范围。所以我假设你读过或者至少在某个时间点浏览过它。我读过，不过现在你要是考我这个，我也记不清里面具体有什么了。
But I have read it. Yes. Was Richard, Richard Bird also did a couple of other books. I'm thinking, do you thinking functionally with Haskell? Is that Richard Bird? The Tiger book? I know the, is the tiger book the designing algorithms with Haskell?
但我确实读过。是的。理查德，理查德·伯德还写过其他几本书。我在想，你是不是在想《Haskell函数式编程》（Thinking Functionally with Haskell）？那是理查德·伯德写的吗？那本老虎书？我知道，老虎书是《Haskell程序设计算法》（Designing Algorithms with Haskell）吗？
That was written by Byrd and co-authored by Jeremy Gibbons. Give me two seconds here. Okay. So here are the books I was thinking of. The tiger book is thinking functionally with Haskell. Okay. So there's two tiger books. Well, the other one is a lion book.
那是伯德写的，和杰里米·吉本斯（Jeremy Gibbons）合著的。给我两秒钟。好的。所以我当时想的是这些书。老虎书是《Haskell函数式编程》。好吧。所以有两本老虎书。嗯，另外一本是狮子书。
Oh, it's a lion book. algorithm design with Haskell. That's what you just said, Richard Bird and Jeremy Gibbons. I actually have not the algebra of programming, but the fun of programming by more of the usual suspects. Jeremy Gibbons and Ergadamor. Probably mispronouncing that, sorry, it's probably Dutch. And this book is also one I was thinking of,
哦，这是一本狮子书。《Haskell算法设计》（Algorithm Design with Haskell）。这正是你刚才说的，理查德·伯德和杰里米·吉本斯合著的。我其实没有《程序代数》，但我有更多熟面孔写的《程序设计之趣》（The Fun of Programming）。杰里米·吉本斯（Jeremy Gibbons）和埃尔加达莫尔（Ergadamor）。我可能发音不准，抱歉，这可能是荷兰语。这本书也是我当时想到的其中一本，
pearls of functional algorithm design. This is a fantastic book. Really good. We've got to put that on my list My ever-growing list That's a risk of talking to Ben folks So don't think you're going to help He's going to help you get through your reading list
《函数式算法设计珍珠》（Pearls of Functional Algorithm Design）。这是一本极好的书。真的很好。我们得把它列入我的书单，我那不断增长的书单。这就是和本聊天所要承担的风险，伙计们。所以别指望他能帮你。他只会帮你读完你的书单。
He's only going to add to it I literally have books sitting on my shelf That I purchased years ago I still have the annotated Alice in Wonderland And I tell myself every Christmas Because I don't know why But it seems like Christmas is the right time You got a little bit of a few days off
他只会不断往里面加书。我的书架上确实摆着一些书。是我多年前买的。我甚至还有带批注的《爱丽丝梦游仙境》。我每次过圣诞节时都告诉自己，因为我不知道为什么，但似乎圣诞节是个好时机，你有几天假，
To read the book Still have not been sitting on my shelf It's a beautiful book Oh you should read it It's great. I know. Every time I mention it, you say the same thing. He's like, ah, you got to put that at the top of your list.
可以把这本书读了。结果书依然好好地在我的书架上呆着。这是一本好书。哦，你应该读读。太棒了。我知道。每次我提到它，你都说同样的话。你就像是在说，啊，你得把它排在书单的最顶端。
And I'm actually listening to an audiobook that Phineas Porter, a past guest on ADSP. He recommended me a book called The Fund, which is a book about the myth of Ray Dalio and kind of his, I don't actually know much about Ray Dalio, other than he's got Bridgewater, et cetera. Anyways, he told me to read that book like a month and a half, or a year and a half. ago and I immediately purchased it and I'm only just getting around to reading it. It's too little time in the day. We need whatever, Dr. Strange's ability to astral project and read stuff while you sleep. Well, I recently reread the annotated Alice and I'm probably going to read it again in the next month because the talk I'm giving at C++ now is the Plato, McGrath, Sartre and Carol talk. So you're doing research. You're doing research for
我实际上在听一本有声书，是菲尼斯·波特（Phineas Porter）推荐给我的，他是 ADSP 以前的嘉宾。他给我推荐了一本叫《基金》（The Fund）的书，这是一本关于雷·达里奥（Ray Dalio）的神话以及他诸如此类事情的书，其实我对雷·达里奥了解不多，只知道他有桥水基金（Bridgewater）等等。总之，他让我大概在一年半前读这本书，我立刻就买了，直到现在才抽空开始读。一天的时间太少了。我们需要像奇异博士那样能够星体投影，并在睡觉时阅读东西的能力。嗯，我最近重读了带批注的《爱丽丝》，我可能在接下来的一个月里还要再读一遍，因为我在 C++ Now 大会上要做的演讲是关于柏拉图、麦格拉思、萨特和卡罗尔的演讲。所以你在做研究。你在为
your upcoming talk. It's one of the best ways if you really want to force yourself to do something is to sign up to give a talk. There you go. You've already read the book. So, all right. The Pearl of Functional Programming by Richard Bird is now on my list again. I did while you were...
即将到来的演讲做研究。如果你真的想强迫自己去做某件事，最好的方法之一就是报名做一个演讲。你看。你已经读过这本书了。所以，好吧。理查德·伯德的《函数式编程珍珠》现在又回到了我的书单上。刚才当你在……
Pels of functional algorithm design. Or functional algorithm design. Oh, there we go. Google knew what I was looking for. And is that a book that's in... So first of all, we've got to figure out what year. It is copyright 2010, which means... It's probably the Haskell phase.
《函数式算法设计珍珠》。或者叫函数式算法设计。哦，找到了。谷歌知道我在找什么。这是一本在……首先，我们得弄清楚是哪一年出版的。它的版权日期是 2010 年，这意味着……它可能正值 Haskell 的发展期。
Yeah, looks like it. Yes. It looks like the code in here is Haskell. Yeah, I've got like a little Google preview. And I'm looking at zip filter, repeat. And so what's curious, I mean, how did I end up going down this rabbit hole? I was doing some work-related stuff, and I stumbled across some stuff that made me think of a paper that my boss put on my radar. like two or three years ago in 2020.
是的，看起来是这样。是的。这里的代码看起来是 Haskell。是的，我看到了一个谷歌的小预览。我正在看 zip、filter、repeat。所以奇怪的是，我是怎么掉进这个兔子洞的呢？我当时在做一些与工作相关的事情，无意中发现了一些东西，让我想起我老板在两三年前（2020年）推荐给过我的一篇论文。
And it was a paper called the algebraic, 1989 algebraic identities for program calculation. And it's only like a seven or eight page paper, I want to say. Okay. It is... Who's the author? Richard Bird. And I didn't actually realize when my boss put the paper on my radar
那是一篇名为《1989年程序计算的代数恒等式》（1989 Algebraic Identities for Program Calculation）的论文。我想它只有七八页长。好的。它是……作者是谁？理查德·伯德。当我的老板把这篇论文推荐给我时，我其实并没有意识到
that it was written by the same individual that had written algebra programming because that's what I most closely associate Bird with at the time. So I haven't read any of Byrd's textbooks, but I am aware it is at the top of my list of books to read as the algebra programming. And I go back to this paper and it's a really, really fascinating, I would probably put it in my top five papers that I've read, along with Frazal Forms by Ken Iverson and a couple others.
它是写《程序代数》的那个人写的，因为当时我对伯德的印象主要跟那本书联系在一起。所以我还没读过伯德的任何教科书，但我知道它排在我待读书单的最顶部，也就是《程序代数》。我又回过头去看这篇论文，它真的非常非常迷人，如果让我排个序，我大概会把它列入我读过的前五名论文中，同列的还有肯·艾verson（Ken Iverson）的《Frazal Forms》以及其他几篇。
And it walks through the Cadane's algorithm, maximum contiguous suboray sum. And he shows a program. transformation from the max of the sum of segments. I think it's max of mapping the sum over segments, where segments are every single possible contiguous subarray. So it's like a cubic, you know, algorithm not very efficient. And he using these algebraic laws transforms that program into a,
它详细讲解了卡达恩算法（Kadane's algorithm），也就是最大连续子数组和。他展示了一个程序转换，从分段和的最大值（max of the sum of segments）开始。我想那是对分段求和进行映射的最大值，其中的分段是指所有可能的连续子数组。所以它类似于一个三次方的算法，效率不是很高。他利用这些代数定律将该程序转化为一个
the linear Cadane's algorithm solution. And in the midst of that paper, he mentioned something called the fold, scan fusion law, which is that if you have a scan succeeded by a fold, you can merge those two essentially and basically end up with a single fold and therefore you don't have to materialize the result of the scan. Yeah. Which is great because it's still linear in time complexity, but now it's constant in space complexity, which is a fantastic improvement.
线性的卡达恩算法解法。在那篇论文的中段，他提到了一个叫做“折叠-扫描融合律”（fold scan fusion law）的东西，也就是说，如果你有一个扫描（scan）后面紧跟着一个折叠（fold），你可以本质上将这两者合并，最终基本上得到一个单一的折叠，因此你不需要实例化扫描的结果。是的。这太棒了，因为它在时间复杂度上仍然是线性的，但现在在空间复杂度上是常数级别的，这是一个了不起的改进。
Very nice. And I, you know, thought it was a cool paper, but it didn't really think too much more of it. But somewhere in the paper, he says, you know, this is just one of many laws. And at the time I was like, well, I don't have time to go on some deep dive. But now, thanks to these little research engines we have, I this time looking at it, went and did like a little research engine. And it came up with a bunch of stuff, which is like the history of this kind of not necessarily program transformation. So that's what the BMF, the Bird Merton's formalism,
非常好。我当时觉得这是一篇很酷的论文，但并没有多想。不过论文中的某个地方，他说，你知道，这只是众多定律之一。当时我想，好吧，我可没时间去深入钻研。但现在，多亏了我们拥有的这些小型研究引擎，这次我看着看着，就用研究引擎查了一下。它搜出了一大堆东西，比如这种不一定非得是程序转换的东西的历史。这就是 BMF，即伯德-默顿形式化（Bird Merton's formalism），
and then later on this language called squiggle. It's all about like stating these algebraic laws, some that are as simple as like the last element of a scan is equal to the equivalent reduction. Right. And some, you know, some of them are even simpler. Like the first element of some kind of mapping operation is, can just, can just be like first or last or something like that. some of the algebra laws almost seem obvious. Yeah. Oftentimes that's the case, of course. Yeah, but if you need those obvious laws to be a part of your algebra in order to do like the full transformations and whatnot.
然后是后来被称为“横折线”（squiggle）的语言。这一切都是关于陈述这些代数定律，有些简单得就像“扫描的最后一个元素等于等效的归约（reduction）”。没错。有些（你知道的）甚至更简单。比如某种映射操作的第一个元素可以仅仅是第一个或最后一个之类的。有些代数定律几乎看起来显而易见。是的。通常情况确实如此，当然。是的，但如果你需要这些显而易见的定律作为代数的一部分，以便进行诸如此类的完整转换，
But I am less interested in program transformations per se than I am in the idea of just building like libraries or languages in the case of Haskell where you can automatically avoid these materializations, which essentially is what like ranges in C++ is, right? Like, you're smirking, you've got something to say. No, what confused me was what, the way you just said that, you said, I'm less interested in program transformations than in making these libraries that do program transformations. So I sort of think there's the same thing what you just said, right?
但我对程序转换本身的兴趣，远不如对构建库或语言（以 Haskell 为例）这种想法的兴趣大，在这些语言中，你可以自动避免这些实例化过程，这本质上不就是 C++ 中的 ranges 做的事情吗？对吧？你在坏笑，你有什么要说的。不对，让我感到困惑的是你刚才说的那种方式，你说：我对程序转换的兴趣不如对制作这些能进行程序转换的库的兴趣大。所以我觉得你刚才说的是同一回事，对吧？
Is it the same thing, though? I mean, that's a good, great question. Maybe it is the same thing. because is the implementation of a library like ranges in C++ or iterators in Rust or streams in Java? Is that the same thing as programmatically transforming one program into a more efficient program? Well, I think in the best case, it is the same. There are a few examples of that in ranges, I think. and I don't think they are at all formalized.
但这真的是同一回事吗？我的意思是，这是一个很好的、伟大的问题。也许这就是同一回事。因为像 C++ 中的 ranges 库、Rust 中的迭代器或 Java 中的流（streams）这样的库的实现，这和以编程方式将一个程序转换为更高效的程序是一回事吗？嗯，我认为在最好的情况下，它们是一回事。我认为 ranges 中有一些这样的例子。而且我认为它们根本没有被形式化。
I don't think they really use program transformation formalisms or laws. I think they are just sort of ad hoc empirical observations in most cases. Things like if you do a reverse view of a reverse view, then what you get back is the original view unwrapped. Right? There's no need to wrap it twice because that double wrapping is the same as if you hadn't wrapped it. Mm-hmm. So wait, what did you say there? You said that it was an ad hoc observation.
我不认为它们真的使用了程序转换的形式化方法或定律。在大多数情况下，我认为它们只是一种特设的（ad hoc）经验观察。比如，如果你对一个反向视图（reverse view）再做一个反向视图，你得到的结果就是解包后的原始视图。对吧？没有必要包装两次，因为这种双重包装和没有包装是一样的。嗯哼。等等，你刚才说什么来着？你说那是一种特设的观察。
What was the... My feeling is that these things are just ad hoc sort of things as they're empirically observed. You know, they, I don't think that, I could be wrong, but I don't think that implementers or API designers in C+++, oftentimes sit down with the background of these formalisms in their mind. they put together useful algorithms, algorithms that have proved to be useful in everyday, their day-to-day life and what people have asked for,
那是什么……我的感觉是，这些东西只是经验观察得出的特设事物。你知道的，它们……我可能搞错了，但我认为 C++ 中的实现者或 API 设计者通常不会带着这些形式化方法的背景坐在那里思考。他们只是组合出有用的算法，这些算法在他们日常生活中以及人们的要求下被证明是有用的，
and they see opportunities for optimizations, right? A lot of times when we program C++ in particular, we're always thinking about how can we make this fast. And so we tend to see empirically opportunities for optimizations. In my experience, we don't often get to that point coming from formalisms. That's what I'm saying. I mean, and that's exactly what we're talking about, folks.
并且他们看到了优化的机会，对吧？很多时候，当我们在编写 C++ 时，我们总是在考虑如何让代码变得更快。因此，我们往往凭经验看到优化的机会。根据我的经验，我们通常不会从形式化方法出发达到那一步。这就是我想说的。我的意思是，这正是我们在讨论的，伙计们。
I mean, I'm thinking my gears are spinning. They're turning in my head. And I guess that is what I become very curious about. And we kind of skipped a couple, or I don't know if we skipped or we just went on tangents and now we're coming back. But, you know, we mentioned Haskell Deforestation, which is a term that I had never heard of. And the paper that I had been, that was put on my radar by the, you know, research engines are a shortcut to deforestation, 1993, by Gill, Launchbury, and Peyton Jones.
我的意思是，我在思考，我的大脑在飞速运转。它们在我的脑海里转动。我想这就是我变得非常好奇的地方。我们好像跳过了一些，或者我不知道我们是跳过了还是只是扯远了，现在又绕了回来。但是，你知道，我们提到了 Haskell 删除树（Deforestation），这是一个我从未听说过的术语。我一直在关注的论文是被……研究引擎推送到我的雷达范围里的，那是吉尔（Gill）、朗斯伯里（Launchbury）和佩顿·琼斯（Peyton Jones）在 1993 年写的《删除树的捷径》（A Short Cut to Deforestation）。
And the little summary of it is basically it introduces this kind of fold R, which it consumes and destructs a list, and then build, which is like a, you know, generator or a producer. You know, there's a bunch of different names for these things over time. But in this 1990-3 paper, they're calling it the fold R slash build rule. Whereas if you, like, chain these things together, you can basically, you know, it's like if you're, if you're summing up an iota sequence, you don't actually have to build. Okay. Okay. This is like, this is fusing together an anamorphism and a catamorphism. Exactly.
它的简短总结基本上是引入了一种叫做 `foldr` 的东西，它消耗并析构一个列表，然后是 `build`，它就像是一个生成器或生产者。（随着时间的推移，这些东西有很多不同的名字）。但在 1993 年的这篇论文中，他们称之为 `foldr/build` 规则。如果你把这些东西链式组合起来，基本上，你知道，就像你在对一个 iota 序列求和时，你实际上不需要去构建它。好的。好的。这就好比将一个 anamorphism 和一个 catamorphism 融合在一起。完全正确。
If we were to go to that terminology. Yes. And it's so crazy sometimes how this stuff works, because I was talking to. Is that called a hylomorphism? Yes, yes, hylomorphism. Yes, highlo-morphism. And you actually put this on my radar at one point, and I recall you explaining it to me, and I maybe nodded my head. And I was like, ah, that makes sense.
如果我们用那种术语来表达的话。是的。有时这东西运作的方式真是太疯狂了，因为我当时在跟……这叫 hylomorphism 吗？是的，是的，hylomorphism。是的，hylomorphism。你曾经在某个时候把它放到了我的雷达里，我记得你向我解释过，我可能点了点头。然后我想，啊，这讲得通。
But it's one of those times where you're kind of squinting and being like, I mean, in theory, it makes sense. But let's hope you don't expect me to explain it to anybody else because I didn't really understand it that well. But yes, hyalomorphism is the combination of anamorphism and a catamorphism. Right. So the animorphism is a, what's the word, the opposite of a fold? Where you're going from a seed value. It's an unfold. Yeah, an unfold.
但有些时候，你会眯起眼睛，心里想：理论上讲，这确实讲得通。但千万别指望我能向其他人解释清楚，因为我其实并没有真正理解它。不过是的，hylomorphism 就是 anamorphism 和 catamorphism 的结合。没错。所以 anamorphism 是一个，怎么说呢，折叠的对偶？也就是你从一个种子值出发。它是一个 unfold（展开）。是的，一个 unfold。
Going from a seed value to a sequence, let's say. Yeah. And catamorphism is the generalization of going from a fold. of a fault going from a sequence to a summation value. Yeah. And so the hyalomorphism is where you fuse them both together. You don't need to generate the sequence in the middle, as it were, and you go to 01 space, like you would just say.
比方说，从一个种子值到一个序列。是的。而 catamorphism 则是将折叠进行泛化。从一个折叠，从一个序列到一个求和值。是的。所以 hylomorphism 就是把它们两者融合在一起的地方。你不需要在中间生成这个序列，你可以直接进入 01 空间，就像你刚才说的那样。
Yeah. And so, I mean, this is, and this is what's kind of interesting, is that, like, it's 2026 right now. This paper was written in the 90s, but, like, it's crazy to think that if we go back 50 years ago, like, people didn't have terminology for talking about this stuff. and like at a certain point like I remember reading one of, or not reading, but perusing Alexander Stepanov's papers on his, you know, Papers.Html page. And I think it's on like higher order notes on scheme or something like that.
是的。所以，我的意思是，这就是有趣的地方，现在是 2026 年。这篇论文写于 90 年代，但是，回想 50 年代，人们居然没有专门的术语来谈论这些东西，这真是太疯狂了。
And on page like 86, he's got an implementation in scheme of reduce. And he's got a little comment that says like, you know, reduce comes from APL. But just this, the idea that like, oh, this reduction operation is a thing that we need to name. and it's like a higher order function. Right. It seems like, what are we talking about? Like, that's obvious. Like, every language I've ever used has, like, in one form or another, reduce function. And, but, you know, Alexander Stepanov was naming this and, like, pointing at APL.
在某个时刻，我记得我曾阅读过——或者说不是阅读，而是浏览过亚历山大·斯捷潘诺夫（Alexander Stepanov）关于他的 Papers.Html 页面的论文。我想它大概在关于 scheme 的高阶笔记之类的页面上。
You're 15 to 20 years younger than me, Connor, right? So the same is not, like, there's no reduce in basic. There's no, as far as I know. I guess that's true. There's no reduce in Pascal. There's no reduce in the languages that I. learned as a child as a teenager. There's no reducing, is there reducing Fortran? I don't know. I mean, they're, they're, Fortran is pretty barebones at least, Fortran 77 as I learned it
在第 86 页左右，他在 scheme 中实现了一个 reduce。他有一个简短的评论，上面写着：“你知道，reduce 来自 APL。”但仅仅是这种想法——哦，这个归约（reduction）操作是我们必须要命名的事情，而且它是一个高阶函数。没错。这似乎在说，我们在谈论什么？这不是很明显吗？我用过的每一种语言，都以这样或那样的方式拥有 reduce 函数。但是，你知道，亚历山大·斯捷潘诺夫当时正在为这个命名，并且指着 APL。
back in the day. So yeah, I guess it depends on when you started your programming journey. But I mean, anyways, this is just like a side note that I'm reading this kind of history of papers that started in the 90s of this idea of, you know, call it what you will. And I'm Metamorphism plus catamorphism equals halomorphism. This paper's calling it Foldar slash-Bel-R rule. Yeah, I don't, in my everyday life, I don't go around throwing these high-faluton Greek-derived terms around. Hylomorphism, that's the one I remember because of the sort of pneumonia of sort of going
Connor，你比我年轻 15 到 20 岁，对吧？所以情况并非如此，比如在 Basic 语言里是没有 reduce 的。据我所知没有。我想这倒也是。在 Pascal 里没有 reduce。在我小时候、青少年时期学过的语言中没有 reduce。Fortran 里有 reduce 吗？我不知道。我的意思是，它们，Fortran 至少是非常精简的，正如我在过去的日子里所学到的 Fortran 77 那样，
high than going low, sort of expanding out and contracting back. Yeah. I mean, so the thing is, I agree, very high-falutin words, but we need a way. to talk about this stuff, right? Exactly. When you're defining, like Dykstra said, the purpose of abstraction is to create a new level
所以，是的，我想这取决于你是什么时候开始你的编程之旅的。但无论如何，这只是一个题外话，我正在阅读这种始于 90 年代的论文历史，关于这种理念的演变，不管你怎么称呼它。元态射（Metamorphism）加上分解态射（catamorphism）等于混合态射（hylomorphism）。这篇论文称之为 Foldar  slash-Bel-R 规则。是的，我不会在日常生活中到处抛出这些高大上的希腊语衍生术语。Hylomorphism，这个我记得是因为那种由高到低、先展开后收缩的助记法。是的。我的意思是，所以情况是这样的，我同意，这些词确实非常高大上，但我们需要一种方式
on which we can be absolutely precise. It's not trying to be fuzzy about these things. If you are working in that space, you need the terms to work with and be precise. Yeah. And so we have the fold-build rule from this paper, but then there's another paper that was published in 2007 called StreamFusion
来谈论这些东西，对吧？没错。正如迪杰斯特拉（Dijkstra）所说，抽象的目的是创造一个新的层面，在这个层面上我们可以做到绝对精确。它并不是要对这些事情含糊不清。如果你在该领域工作，你就需要这些术语来开展工作并保持精确。是的。所以我们从这篇论文中得到了 fold-build 规则，但随后在 2007 年又发表了另一篇名为《流融合：从列表到流，再到虚无》（StreamFusion from lists to streams to nothing at all）的论文，它在 fold-build 框架的基础上进行了构建，然后将其他东西加入到所谓的融合规则中，比如 zips、can cap maps、take and drop 等等。因此，似乎有一段历史文献表明，你不仅可以避免实例化并减少内存占用，不仅仅是通过 build 和 fold，你还可以将 map 融合在一起。
from lists to streams to nothing at all, that builds on the fold build framework, but then adds other things to the fusion quote-unquote rules, like zips, can cap maps, take and drop, et cetera. And so it seems that there's like a history of papers that are showing that like you can do more than just like avoid materialization and like reduce your memory footprints than just like, you know, build and fold, you know, maps you can fuse together.
你知道的，我最喜欢的、包括迈克尔·凯斯（Michael Case）在内的许多人都在用的 zip-tail 技巧，奥丁·霍尔姆斯（Odin Holmes）、伊万（Ivan）甚至是库切克（Kuchek）——我总是把他的名字读错，不过，你知道的，她是《C++中的函数式编程》（Functional Programming in C++）的作者。通过这种所谓的惰性操作，你可以避免许多实例化。不管怎样，我一直在努力在脑子里把这些东西理清楚，因为你说过，是的，很多实现这些东西的人，
You know, the, my favorite, the zip tail trick that many people, including Michael Case, I think, Odin Holmes, Ivan or even Kuchek, I always mess up his pronunciation of his name, but, you know, author of the functional programming in C++. A lot of these, you can avoid materialization by doing this kind of, quote unquote, lazy operations. And it, anyways, I've just been trying to sort all this stuff in my head because you're saying that, yeah, a lot of people that implement this stuff. They're not going to some set of academic papers and being like, here is an algebra that I can then implement and here are all the lazy operations. Well, I think, I think in some ways we might come out with better outcomes if people did that more. But my point is they're not, they're not working in that highly, they're not mathematicians, right? They're not working mathematicians. They're working programmers. They're working library writers. Their first job is to
他们并不是去翻阅某堆学术论文，然后心想：“这里有一个我可以实现的代数，这里面有所有的惰性操作。”嗯，我觉得，在某些情况下，如果人们更多地这样做，我们可能会取得更好的成果。但我的观点是，他们没有，他们没有在那种高度运作，他们不是数学家，对吧？他们不是在职的数学家。他们是工作中的程序员。他们是库的编写者。他们的首要工作是
produce something that's usable, performs well, and fulfills use cases. Right. So their focus is not necessarily in using formalisms to achieve that. And now I think there's a level of like, let's, it behooves us to recognize what we're doing, right? This is what I always, I always think. The process of writing code is, and producing nice code, producing beautiful code is in many ways, recognizing what it is you're actually doing. And sometimes, you know, sometimes the mathematics helps with that. Yeah. It's like we said before, like you can be a good baker without studying chemistry.
生产出可用、性能良好且满足用例的东西。没错。所以他们的重点不一定在于使用形式化方法来实现这一点。现在我认为，有一种层次需要我们去认识到我们正在做的事情，对吧？这就是我一直以来所想的。编写代码的过程，以及产出精美代码、产出漂亮代码的过程，在很多方面都是在认识你实际上在做什么。而且有时，你知道，数学有时会有所帮助。是的。就像我们之前说的，你可以不用学习化学就能成为一个优秀的烘焙师。
Yeah. Right? But if you are a good baker, odds are you kind of know chemistry, at least as far as it relates to baking. And studying chemistry can make you a better baker. So I think that, you know, it's that same analogy applies to programming and this kind of mathematics. Yeah. I mean, I feel like I'm a bad baker and a bad chemist, but I've got a lot of thoughts on like the chemistry. Well, I live at altitude, so baking is a little bit trickier usually.
是的。对吧？但如果你是一个优秀的烘焙师，大概率你对化学还是有所了解的，至少在它与烘焙相关的范围内是这样。而学习化学可以让你成为一个更好的烘焙师。所以我认为，那种类比同样适用于编程和这种数学。是的。我的意思是，我觉得我既是个糟糕的烘焙师，又是个糟糕的化学家，但我对化学有很多想法。嗯，我住在高海拔地区，所以烘焙通常要棘手一些。
I've had some bakes come out poorly. Really? Altitude makes a difference? It certainly does. Oh, well, that's good to know. I guess I live at roughly sea level, so I guess I have it as easy as it gets then. Well, yes, most recipes you find are designed for sea level baking. Altitude requires some adjustment sometimes.
我有些烘焙成果做得很糟糕。真的吗？海拔有影响吗？当然有。哦，那很高兴知道。我想我大概住在海平面附近，那我大概算得上拥有最简单的烘焙条件了？嗯，是的，你找到的大多数食谱都是为海平面烘焙设计的。高海拔有时需要做一些调整。
Really? I had no idea. I had no idea. Anyways, all of this is to say that I feel like there's a, I don't know, there's a through line here from these, you know, academic papers and formalisms and algebras and calculi, whatever you want to call them, which like I said, I'm not a trained mathematician. And I'm doing my best to read the academies and parse this stuff. But then the other day I actually was trying to figure out, like, who was the original implementer of, like, the boost range V1? I know there's, like, there's boost ranges 2.0. Because V3 is the one we'll know.
真的吗？我完全不知道。我一点也不知道。无论如何，所有这些都是为了说明，我觉得这里有一条……我不知道，这里有一条贯穿线，连接着这些学术论文、形式化方法、代数和演算，随便你怎么称呼它们——就像我说的，我不是受过专业训练的数学家，我正在尽我所能阅读学术论文并解析这些东西。但前几天我实际上在试图弄清楚，谁才是 boost range V1 的最初实现者？我知道有 boost range 2.0，因为 V3 是我们所熟知的那个版本。
Yeah. So did Eric implement V1 and V2 before V3? I don't know. No, I don't think he did. I mean, if you go to boost ranges, if you Google it, it comes up with 2.0, and then it says copyright of Thorsten Autosin and Niel. Greaves. Those names are not familiar to me. But then also is 2.0 an evolution of 1.0, which they wrote, or is it the same thing that happened with V3? And it has me very curious of, at what point did the, like, you know, and you can tell me, you've been programming in C++
是的。那么 Eric 在 V3 之前实现过 V1 和 V2 吗？我不知道。不，我不认为他做过。我的意思是，如果你去搜 boost ranges，如果你在谷歌上搜它，会出现 2.0 版本，然后上面写着版权所有者是托尔斯滕·奥托辛（Thorsten Autosin）和尼尔·格里夫斯（Niel Greaves）。这些名字我并不熟悉。但话说回来，2.0 是他们写的 1.0 的演变版本，还是跟 V3 发生的情况一样？这让我非常好奇，什么时候……你知道的，你可以告诉我，你编写 C++
plus much longer. And you've also been doing high performance stuff because you, you know, worked at, you know, gaming companies before and high frequency firms before. is like is the idea of operating on you know what in boost ranges were called fancy iterators and then kind of evolved to be views in range v3 is this like a modern thing because like I know sick pee had the idea of streams and like those existed in like lisp land and scheme land decades ago yeah because lisp had closures and if you have closures you can make lazy streams yeah and so is is that like the genesis of because there seems to be like definitely there's an academic like paper trail of people writing about this stuff and discovering this stuff and then we live in 2026 today where all modern languages have versions of these kind of stream like fusion like libraries and uh anyways
的时间要长得多。而且你也一直在做高性能方面的工作，因为你以前在游戏公司和高频交易公司工作过。在 boost ranges 中被称为花式迭代器（fancy iterators）的东西，后来演变成 range v3 中的视图（views），这种操作理念是一件很现代的事情吗？因为我知道 SICP 就有流（streams）的概念，几十年前 Lisp 领域和 Scheme 领域就已经存在这些东西了。是的，因为 Lisp 拥有闭包，如果你有了闭包，你就可以制造出惰性的流。是的。所以，这是……这是起源吗？因为这里肯定有一条学术论文的轨迹，记录着人们撰写这些东西、发现这些东西，然后我们生活在今天的 2026 年，所有现代语言都有这些流式、融合式库的版本。无论如何，
i'm just very curious like where did it all start and at what point did people start realizing that you can do like i don't know that you can do these kinds of lazy things was it was it did it come from the functional programming influences of languages adopting? Or does nobody know? And I'm just doing like, what do you call it? Programming language archaeology. Well, programming language archaeology is a lot of fun, of course. And I, you know, does nobody know?
我只是非常好奇这一切是从哪里开始的，人们在什么时候开始意识到你可以像——我不知道——你可以做这些惰性的事情？它是从采用这些特性的语言中的函数式编程影响中诞生的吗？还是说根本没人知道？我只是在做……你们把它叫什么？编程语言考古学。嗯，编程语言考古学当然是一件很有趣的事情。而且我……难道真的没人知道吗？
I think the question really is, well, maybe that question, maybe the question is stated isn't worth answering. But we can only, we can observe what's happened, right? which is the history of programming languages, and in particular in the last 20 years, depending on which language you use in your day job, you know, that you will have noticed the influence sooner or later.
我想真正的问题是，也许那个问题，也许这样提出的问题不值得去回答。但我们只能观察已经发生的事情，对吧？也就是编程语言的历史，特别是过去 20 年里，取决于你在日常工作中使用的语言，你会或早或晚地注意到这种影响。
But functional languages have for sure been influencing mainstream languages, if you like, for at least 20 years, probably a little bit longer, you know. And so, so, you know, back in the earlier days, we had Fortran, you had LISP, those were two very different takes on computation, right? Fortran embodying the sort of von Neumann machine architecture,
但函数式语言无疑一直在影响着主流语言，如果可以这么说的话，至少有 20 年了，可能还要更久一些，你知道的。所以，你知道，在早期的时候，我们有 Fortran，有 Lisp，那是对计算的两种截然不同的看法，对吧？Fortran 体现了冯·诺伊曼机器架构，
Lisp embodying the Lambda calculus. We go forward a little bit, we have, you know, the, and we can sort of, if we squint, think of those as the pragmatic camp and the mathematical camp, or the camp, you know, the camp, which is concerned with what hardware does, and the camp which is concerned with maybe more mathematical ideas. That's probably a very unfair generalization
而 Lisp 体现了 Lambda 演算。我们再往前看一点，我们有……我们可以稍微眯起眼睛，把它们看作务实阵营和数学阵营，或者说是关心硬件在做什么的阵营，以及可能更关心数学理念的阵营。这可能是一个非常不公平的概括，
because, you know, it's not like the people who make programming languages are in general well versed in the mathematics, right? It's not like the folks who made Fortran were not mathematicians. They absolutely were mathematicians. But, you know, then we move through the 70s and we see C and we see ML, right, 1973. And then as we move into the 80s, we see, and beyond, we see a proliferation of the mainstream, sort of C-derived languages. And then we see the web and we see things coming in from the functional side.
因为，你知道，这并不是说制作编程语言的人普遍不精通数学，对吧？制作 Fortran 的人并非不是数学家。他们绝对是数学家。但是，你知道，当我们穿过 70 年代，看到 C 语言和 ML 语言（1973年）。然后当我们进入 80 年代及以后，我们看到了主流的、从 C 衍生出的语言的大爆发。接着我们看到了互联网，看到了从函数式那边引入的东西。
You know, JavaScript at its core has a lot of things in common with a Lisp, right? So it pulls from both camps, if you like. And then it's very, you know, in the last 10, 15, 20 years, very in vogue for the mainstream, what we might have considered, you know, C++ until until 2000, maybe, until 2005 even, we would have put in the machine sympathetic camp, right, squarely. But, but now C++, certainly for the last decade plus, 15 plus years even, has had a lot of influence from the functional site, you know. You go to any C++ conference, you'll hear people talking about monads. And, you know, folks who work in functional languages are like, you know, it's nice that
你知道的，JavaScript 的核心与 Lisp 有很多共同点，对吧？所以它汲取了两个阵营的养分，如果你愿意这么说的话。然后，你知道的，在过去的 10 年、15 年、20 年里，对于主流语言来说非常流行，我们可能认为（比如 2000 年之前的 C++，甚至直到 2005 年）你会把 C++ 毫不犹豫地归入机器同情阵营（machine sympathetic camp）。但是，现在 C++，至少在过去十多年、甚至十五年多的时间里，受到了来自函数式方面的很多影响，你知道的。你走到任何一个 C++ 会议上，都会听到人们谈论单子（monads）。而且，你知道，在函数式语言中工作的人会觉得，孩子们现在正在学习这些基础概念，这挺不错的。
kids are learning about these elementary concepts now. Introducing lambdas. You've never heard of anything like. Exactly. C++ only got lambdas in 2011, in C++ plus 11. Mind you, C++11 is now further away than C++ plus 98 was from C++ 11, right? C++ plus 11 was over half a standard lifetime ago.
引入了 lambda 表达式。你从来没听说过类似的东西。没错。C++ 直到 2011 年的 C++11 中才引入了 lambda 表达式。请记住，现在的 C++11 距离我们已经比当年的 C++98 距离 C++11 还要遥远了，对吧？C++11 已经过去了一个标准生命周期的一半以上了。
Oh, wow, yeah. But, you know, so the languages that I work in, have worked in for my entire career, I'm happy to see are getting more influence from the functional side of things because that is, you know, and generic programming is very functional in nature as well, as a paradigm.
哦，哇，是的。但是，你知道的，我一直在使用的语言，我整个职业生涯都在使用的语言，我很高兴看到它们正受到来自函数式事物越来越多的影响，因为那是，你知道的，泛式编程作为一种范式，本质上也具有很强的函数式特征。
Because that seems to be the best way we've found so far to achieve actual useful composition, to achieve actual useful reasonability of the code. And it's the declarative functional style that gives us that. So I guess in that story, it comes from the functional influences. I guess. I mean, I probably cut tons out of that story.
因为这似乎是我们迄今为止找到的实现真正有用的组合、实现代码真正有用的可推理性的最佳途径。正是这种声明式的函数式风格赋予了我们这一点。所以我想在这个故事里，它来自于函数式的潜移默化。我想是的。我的意思是，我可能从这个故事里删掉了大量的细节，
you know, there are lots of languages along the way that, in a way, all languages sort of influence each other. And so I didn't mention language, you know, some very influential languages, which are not... Small talkers out there going, no, you didn't mention small talk. There's languages like self and clue, and there's languages like Ada. Yeah. You know, that pioneered what we might think of as aspects of object orientation or aspects of generic programming. Yeah. Yeah, I've got to continue doing my archaeology in because I really feel like there's something here, you know.
你知道的，一路走来有很多语言，某种程度上所有的语言都在互相影响。所以我没有提到语言，你知道的，一些非常具有影响力的语言，它们并不是……小黄鸭（Smalltalk）社区的人会站出来说：不，你没有提到 Smalltalk。还有像 Self 和 Clue 这样的语言，还有像 Ada 这样的语言。是的。你知道的，它们开创了我们可能认为是面向对象特征或泛式编程特征的东西。是的。是的，我得继续我的考古工作，因为我真的觉得这里面大有文章，你知道的。
I mean, what is my goal at the end of the day? I work for a company that runs programs on a different architecture, you know, GPUs. And a lot of this literature that's been written about algebraic laws and programming transformation, it implicitly is designed for CPUs. and the quote-unquote fusion laws that are possible on a CPU are not the same as the laws that are possible on a GPU. Okay. The fold scan fusion law, I mean, there's a version of it that can work, but scans are not parallelizable the same way that folds are. A fold can be parallelized essentially in the same kind of way that a CPU would do it. Yeah.
我的最终目标究竟是什么？我为一家在不同架构（GPU）上运行程序的公司工作。许多关于代数定律和程序转换的文献，它们隐式地是为 CPU 设计的。而且 CPU 上可能的所谓“融合律”与 GPU 上可能的定律并不相同。好的。折叠-扫描融合律，我的意思是，有一个版本可以在 GPU 上工作，但扫描不像折叠那样可以并行化。折叠基本上可以以类似于 CPU 的方式进行并行化。是的。
A GPU would do it. But due to the way that a scan... Because the scan has the data dependency. Exactly. Whereas the fold, if you have just an associative operation, you can execute it in any order. Exactly. And so that is a small difference if you're computing, quote, unquote,
GPU 也会这么做。但由于扫描的方式……因为扫描具有数据依赖性。完全正确。而折叠，如果你只有一种结合律操作，你就可以以任何顺序执行它。完全正确。所以如果你在计算，所谓的一——
you know, left to right sequentially. But it's a massive difference if you're trying to parallelize things. And I think the quote unquote, what did you say? You called it ad hoc empirical observations. they become more difficult, you know. Observing that, you know, you can chain maps together and, you know, avoid materializing stuff, I think is pretty straightforward and obvious. I don't know. Maybe not for everybody.
“从左到右依次进行”，这只是一个小区别。但如果你试图进行并行化，那就是一个巨大的区别。而且我认为，所谓的花费——你叫它什么来着？你称之为经验观察的特设事物。它们变得更加困难了，你知道的。观察到你可以将 map 链式组合起来并避免实例化，我认为这相当直接且显眼。我不知道。也许对每个人来说并非如此。
But across different, like, hardware, these, like, implicit algebraic laws actually are less obvious, and there's way more opportunity to leave performance on the floor, especially if you're dispatching to different types of hardware. And so I have this like grand vision in the back of my head that's like there's some truth out there in the form, in some, whether it's a formalism or an algebra or whatever, or maybe none of that stuff. And it's just a thoughtful implementation of a library that like hides that stuff from the user, which is kind of what ranges is, right? Like you compose ranges together. Yeah. You get an efficient slow memory program. Anyways, you're about to say something. I agree. I was going to say I agree 100%. Like when you write a library, if you are, if you are, if you're, you. are making these observations, if you are, you know, writing the library to do certain use cases, and you notice you can fold things together, that's great, right? But I agree at some point, like, unless you are like a super genius, I guess, you are going to hit a wall where just the next, you just don't see that these things can be folded together because it's really, really not obvious, right?
但在不同的硬件之间，这些隐式的代数定律实际上并没有那么明显，而且存在着更多的可能性会白白损失性能，特别是当你分发到不同类型的硬件时。因此，在我的脑海深处有一个宏大的愿景，那就是某种真理以外在的形式存在，无论它是一种形式化方法、一种代数、还是别的什么，或者也许这些东西统统没有，它只是一个库的深思熟虑的实现，把那些东西对用户隐藏起来，这有点像 ranges 做的事情，对吧？就像你把 ranges 组合在一起。是的。你就能得到一个高效的低内存程序。无论如何，你刚才正要说点什么。我同意。我本来想说我 100% 同意。就像当你编写一个库时，如果你是——如果你是——如果你正在进行这些观察，如果你正在（你知道的）编写库来处理某些用例，并且你注意到你可以将东西折叠在一起，那太棒了，对吧？但我同意，在某个时候，除非你是一个超级天才，我想，否则你将会撞上一堵墙，因为接下来的事情，你就是看不出这些东西可以折叠在一起，因为这真的、真的很不明显，对吧？
it's very difficult and it's very difficult to recognize what we have written in code, like in that sense. As well I was talking about earlier, the recognition of what we're actually doing. And to do that, you do need to study a bit of the chemistry, right? You do need to study a bit of mathematics. And then that helps you unlock something in the code.
这非常困难，而且很难识别我们在代码中写了什么，从这个意义上说。正如我刚才所说的那样，去识别我们实际上在做什么。要做到这一点，你确实需要学习一点化学，对吧？你确实需要学习一点数学。然后这会帮助你解锁代码中的某些东西。
And then frequently, you know, the experience I've often had is that sometimes the code just melts away, right? When you've decomposed it and you've expressed the mathematics properly, the thing, the thing that you had, which you thought was some kind of kernel of complexity in there that you couldn't crack, right? Actually, that's now been decomposed and parts of it have not just become simpler, but they've actually disappeared. And are you saying that that happens behind the scenes with like a well-designed library, or you're saying that that is something, once you've studied the quote unquote chemistry and math that you as a programmer can kind of tear apart.
然后通常情况下，我经常有的体验是，有时候代码就直接消失了，对吧？当你把它进行分解，并正确地表达了数学原理之后，你原本以为里面有什么无法攻克的复杂性核心，其实现在已经被分解了，其中的一部分不仅变得更简单，而且实际上直接消失了。你是说这在幕后是通过像设计良好的库这样的东西发生的，或者你是说，一旦你研究了所谓的化学和数学，作为程序员你就可以自己去把它剖析开来？
I'm saying in my experience, studying the mathematics and the, and it is the only way I get to that point. Like, I'm not clever enough to write a library that does these things and, and simplify it enough internally without using the mathematics. Right, right, right, right. So yeah, it requires taking the time to, like, whether it's mathematics or chemistry or whatever metaphor. Whatever the analogy is, yeah. Yeah. I don't know. This is what's been dominating, like, my free cycles. Because, you know, my affinity for array languages as well, like, there's so much of, I mean, there's different flavors of this that have come up over the years where at one point I had
我的意思是，根据我的经验，研究数学以及……这确实是我到达那种境界的唯一途径。比如，如果不使用数学，我没有足够的聪明才智去编写一个在内部进行这些事情并足够简化的库。对，对，对，对。所以是的，这需要花时间去了解，不管是数学、化学还是别的什么隐喻。不管是什么类比，是的。是的。我不知道。这就是最近一直占据我空闲时间的东西。因为你知道，我对数组语言也很有好感，这意味着，有很多……我是说，这些年来出现过各种不同的变体，有一次我曾意识到
the realization that, that what happens with, like, iterator tag dispatch, is basically like a form of this, right? You know, you pass a collection to a well-designed, thoughtfully designed algorithm, and depending on the iterator category tags, it'll then dispatch to a certain, you know, algorithm that will be the best performance for the iterator types that have been passed to that algorithm.
迭代器标签分派（iterator tag dispatch）所做的事情，基本上就是这种形式的一种体现，对吧？你知道，你将一个集合传递给一个精心设计、深思熟虑的算法，根据迭代器类别的标签，它会将其分派到某个最适合传递给该算法的迭代器类型的算法中去。
And array languages do this kind of thing by attaching metadata to the container. So, you know, if it's only, Boolean data, ones and zeros, or if it's a sorted container, you know, that's an example of if you have a sorted data and you do first, you know, that's an 01 operation that it's like, well, why would you be writing code where you're taking the first of, you know, something that you just sorted? Well, it's like, well, actually, there's a few different operations that end up with sorted data that are, you can easily forget about. Like, if you do a max scan, that results in
而数组语言通过向容器附加元数据来实现这种事情。所以，你知道，如果它只是布尔数据、1和0，或者如果它是一个有序容器，你知道，这就是一个例子：如果你有有序数据，然后你执行“first”（取第一个元素），你知道，这是一个O(1)操作，这就好比，为什么你要编写这样的代码：对刚刚排序的东西取第一个元素？好吧，其实有一些不同的操作最终会产生有序数据，而你很容易忘掉它们。比如，如果你做一个最大值扫描（max scan），这会导致
sorted data. You might not immediately think about that, but it is a, there are multiple operations that result in these kind of like metadata properties that if you store them and you check just up front before you do some operation, it could lead not to like a, you know, we're talking like a quadratic to linear or quadratic to linear rhythmic. It could be like, what is, n-log-n is linear rhythmic to 0.1, which is like absurd. And, you know, you tell people this and they go, I don't know, that would be obvious. Obviously, no one would ever. You would be surprised at how often, like you.
产生有序数据。你可能不会立刻想到这一点，但确实有多种操作会产生这类元数据属性。如果你存储它们，并且在执行某些操作之前预先检查一下，它可能不会导致……我们说的是从二次方复杂度（quadratic）降到线性复杂度（linear），或者二次方降到线性对数（linearithmic）。这可能是，什么是n log n？是线性对数，而0(1)简直是荒谬的。而且，你知道，你把这个告诉别人，他们会觉得，我不知道，这不是很明显吗。显然没有人会……你会惊讶于有多少次，就像你一样。
Nothing is that obvious. Yeah, I agree. And I started one of my little side projects from a couple years ago was this Jello program that would enable you to type keywords and convert that into a jelly, which is like a code golfing. And even for me, it's a very hard language to remember all the different symbols because they use like the extended character set of, I think it's Spanish or something where it's like over dots and under dots and accents. Oh, wow. So it's not even symbols. and I started, there's a file that's called like hints or something where any time it recognizes
没有什么事情是那么明显的。是的，我同意。几年前我开始的一个小副业项目是这个叫做 Jello 的程序，它能让你输入关键字并将其转换为 Jelly，这有点像代码高尔夫（code golfing）。即使对我来说，要记住所有不同的符号也是一门很难的语言，因为它们使用的是我认为是西班牙语或某种语言的扩展字符集，上面有点，下面有点，还有重音符号。哦，哇！所以它甚至都不是普通的符号。我开始创建一个名为 hints（提示）之类维护的文件，每当它识别出
a composition or some like idiom, it says, oh, you can, you can use this instead because like it's, it's so hard to keep track of all the different little idioms and patterns and things like that. And I would love a language. Like, it's too complicated with a language like C++ that you'd get these little syntactic, like, oh, hey, by the way, you're doing this. You could be doing this and that'll be better for a reason, X, Y, and Z. a language or a library that just hides all of that stuff for you and just whatever you write is the kind of naive, you know, way of expressing your solution. But then, so I guess maybe we are back to program transformations.
某种组合或某种惯用法（idiom）时，它就会说，“哦，你可以用这个来代替”，因为要记住所有这些不同的小惯用法、模式之类的内容实在是太难了。我真希望有一门语言……像 C++ 这样的语言实在是太复杂了，你会得到这些小小的语法提示，比如，“哦，嘿，顺便说一下，你正在这样做，你可以改成那样，因为 X、Y 和 Z 的原因那样会更好。”一门语言或一个库，它为你隐藏了所有这些东西，无论你写出什么样的代码，都是那种朴素的、表达你解决方案的方式。但随后，我想也许我们又回到了程序转换上来。
But what is actually a program transformation? Does a library that does all that stuff? Does that count? Does it matter? I don't know. I think it counts. Whether it happens inside the compiler or in the library, I mean in C++, expression templates are often touted as this kind of thing. right?
但究竟什么是程序转换？一个能做所有这些事情的库算吗？这重要吗？我不知道。我认为它算数。无论它发生在编译器内部还是在库中，我的意思是，在 C++ 中，表达式模板（expression templates）经常被吹捧为这种东西，对吧？
Expression templates count as this thing. They're often cited, I would say. Interesting. So think about like a linear algebra library using expression templates. The reason it uses those is to take what you write and transform it into a machine sympathetic thing. Like, you know, fuse multiplier would be a trivial example, right? Huh. Yeah, I never thought about that.
表达式模板算作这种东西。我想它们经常被引用。有趣的是，想想使用表达式模板的线性 algebra（线性代数）库。它使用这些东西的原因，是将你编写的代码转换为对机器友好的东西。比如，融合乘加（fused multiply-add）就是一个微不足道的例子，对吧？哈。是的，我从没想过这一点。
I mean, this is, it makes my brain hurt of like all of this stuff. It's like, it's all the same stuff at the end of the day. And it makes me think that like we're too early in the computer science. Like we don't actually have a well-formed vocabulary to talk about all this stuff because you find the same patterns. I don't know. This makes me, always makes you think that like Bartaj Maluski is correct in that. He's working on his second book, right, about how, you know, everything's category theory.
我的意思是，这让我的大脑感到痛苦，所有这些东西。归根结底，它们其实都是同一回事。这让我觉得，我们在计算机科学领域还处于太早期。我们实际上没有一个结构良好的词汇表来谈论所有这些东西，因为你会发现相同的模式。我不知道。这总是让你觉得巴特什·马卢斯基（Bartosz Milewski）的观点是正确的，他在写他的第二本书，对吧，关于……你知道的，一切都是范畴论（category theory）。
But then there's some other like higher level category theory where it's like music programming. It's all the same at the end of the day. day, it's just a different spelling. Yeah, maybe. I mean, we can keep generalizing and generalizing, and we get to a point where everything's the same because it's ultimately generalized. Be sure to check these show notes, either in your podcast app or at ADSP thepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a get-up discussion
但随后还有一些其他更高级的范畴论，比如音乐编程。归根结底，它们都是一样的，只是拼写不同而已。是的，也许吧。我的意思是，我们可以不断地进行抽象和泛化，直到我们达到这样一个地步：由于最终都被泛化了，所以一切都变得一模一样。请务必查看这些节目笔记，无论是在您的播客应用程序中，还是在 ADSP thepodcast.com 上，都可以找到我们在今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个 GitHub 讨论的链接
where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. I am the anti-brace. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
您可以在那里留下您的想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。希望您喜欢并度过美好的一天。我是反大括号斗士（anti-brace）。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。